If they can do that and get people
really upset if they really can't do it.
That's a really effective strategy.
It's a great strategy.
Can make things happen now cause it's
just sewing internal discord and we're
going to collapse her own system.
Like I wonder how many of these Jesse
Small a is that? I see his name.
Jesse smell, A's rushing.
The whole thing is Russian.
It's not even real thing is Russian chess.
It's Molly doesn't exist.
I wonder how many of the memes were
created by Russians to try to get people
upset.
I bet this bunch.
I bet there's more people stirring things
up then just Temaze Americans that are
upset. No, I'm sure it's people that are,
but then there's also just a lot of
Americans that hate each other. Does that?
Yeah. Yeah. There's that.
But then you also, what do
you think happens with Jesse?
Small light his empire because
ABC got rid of Roseanne for tweet.
You got to get rid of this guy.
I thought he was getting canceled.
He was getting written out rather
than I read today. But yeah, I dunno.
I thought he was getting written out
before and this is one of the reasons why
he did it. Well, I support him if that's
the case, cause he's a very hard business.
This is a very tough business.
It is hard. It's hard to make it.
I love that they had to plan that out
and he said to the two guys, he goes,
listen, get a noose. Yeah, cool.
Get rope and doing those. All.
A lot of these hate crimes, if, first
of all, I hate crimes happening.
They're horrible.
But some of these things are fic.
Do you know he showed up at the hotel
with the new still around his neck holding
a subway sandwich.
Just that alone,
the people and people at the hotel should
have been like, what? What happened?
That's amazing. Okay,
what happened? Why juice?
It's still at the sandwich and why are
you eating at subway or you're not sick
to your stomach.
You're on empire.
What the Hell's wrong with you in
the wrong subway? Subway's not good.
It's not bad if you're hungry. Listen,
I've, I've clearly hating it. Yeah,
but it ain't great. But if it's
like two o'clock in the morning,
it's the only thing open. Why
is he telling me to, yeah,
that's a great point is it's open.
Okay.
A good move to be open when nothing
else is open. It's a good point.
You get a nice Italian.
So I would double meat.
I like the [inaudible] oil and vinegar,
salt, pepper ball with the Mozzarella,
whatever.
And then you don't toast it.
You let the hot and meatballs melt the
cheese. Ooh, I agree with that. Yeah,
that's a good move. Meatball
sub. It's always a good one.
It's always a good morning.
Especially after faking a hate crime.
After you fake the hate crime. Amit,
both. How nervous you after you do that?
I'm such a pussy. I could never
go. I could never do what.
He did some level associates, but
then I saw that act right. You know,
with the other night, and I went,
oh, he could do that. Yeah. Oh,
these people can do it because
they're on another level. Well,
the other thing is that people say,
who would want to be a victim?
Who'd want to fake being a victim?
I heard that during the cabin off hearing.
I was like,
that is a ridiculous thing to say.
Cause there's a lot of currency
in our business, in our business.
It takes a lot of conflict,
tea in the world,
like people like praise victims for
showing out and they support them.
You get a tremendous amount of love,
especially if you're a legit victim.
Something of course, you know, I
mean there's a lot to that. Yeah.
The idea that no one would do
that is so there's so against,
it's so contrary to human nature. No,
everyone would do it. I want to do it.
What would you do? What kind of hate
crime would you faked? It was great idea.
I don't know if I got punched and
people saw my face, they'd go good.
It deserved it. You know what I mean? Like
nobody would look at my face ago. Yeah.
Okay, good. Well, I wrote, I tweeted
something today. I was like, Hey,
I'm at flappers on uh, what was it?
Uh, my, the 26 of flappers I was,
it was two guys was Hollywood
would Maga hats. They beat me up.
They put something on me.
I don't know what it was.
I think it was come please
come to farmers. But I mean,
that's the thing. Listen,
I watched good morning America
interview this morning. I left,
I sent it to my buddy. I go, there's
a moment in it. When they go,
how'd you know it was the attackers?
And he goes like this. He goes,
and you could see the insanity. You
can see in his eyes. He goes like this.
He goes, I was there and he's
just doing that Shitty actory.
Oh,
like just fucking shitty acting class.
That horse shit. I was there and
I'm like, this is fucking crazy. Oh,
he was going to inform on two guys if
there were two white guys with Maga hats
who got caught.
Oh my God,
I'd be in jail right now because
the detective said to them,
we have two suspects on camera. Do
you think it's Sam? He was like, yeah.
Then he found out it's just two
buddies and he's like, well,
I can't testify against them.
He was going to testify against two
people who they thought were guilty.
So he said that he thought it
was dumb. Yeah. He said, yeah,
there's a good morning America
interview. Oh, have him going? Yeah.
It's those two that takes it to another
level and then Fox, he's like, well,
we stat with, hey, he's good on
the show. We stand behind them.
That takes it to a completely different
way than it would be people in jail
right now. He wouldn't care.
Could you imagine? It's crazy.
Could you imagine not just faking a hate
crime, but then putting people in jail?
Magic being those two guys were just
sitting in jail like, what the fuck?
You're on the cover of the New York
Post. Nab dumb got them, got them,
and they're sitting there like,
what the fuck?
And everybody wants to
kick their ass empire.
Next season is all about Jesse smaller.
They fire everyone else on the show and
it's just a Jesse smallest story and two
innocent people. The Gay Tupac
wandering the streets of empire.
That's why people in Ohio,
whenever Hollywood like,
here's how to vote. They go,
you know what? No. They go, you know what?
No thank you. I see what you're doing.
You fucks faking hate crimes.
What kind of hate crime would you
fake if you're going to do it?
It's a great question. It's
a great question. What if,
what if someone gave you a
license to fake a hate crime?
Like what if there was a television
show about faking a hate crime?
That's how they do at punk. You
know, you are fake things like that.
How about you fake a hate crime?
I'd love to do something like that.
True TV presents. Yes. Fake a hate crime.
Yeah. Yeah. It's interesting. I don't,
I'm trying to think.
Press conference a whole deal.
Maybe a Halaal guy would
attack them in New York City.
Like a Halau guy would attack me.
Um,
because he views me as a
symbol of imperialism and
oppression. There'll be good,
you know, even though I
patronize his stand all the time,
still feels the need to attack. I mean,
I don't know. I could never do that. No.
I'm one of those people who would get,
and I would get caught,
well this would never
think I'd get away with it.
Wanting everyone to think you're a
victim when nothing really happened is
insanely selfish thing. Yeah, that's
an insane like faking physical crime.
Ikea to have someone punch him already
hit himself. Yeah. These marketers,
phase Maggot hat wearing gangs that
everyone's talking about in Chicago and La
and New York do not exist. If you have
a mega hat on at 2:00 AM in New York,
you're getting bleached poured on you.
Yeah,
probably reality will also like just,
he was saying that he like punched him
back and he fought back and I love how he
was like, first of all he was on camera
for everything except one minute.
So they ask him to good morning America.
They go, how long was this? He's like,
it felt like several minutes,
but it could have been 30 seconds.
Like he's covering the span of
time in his, in his lie he's going,
I got to say it's less than a minute
cause I'm only off camera for a minute.
Whenever you hear about a guy like
kills his wife and blames a black guy,
you know there's been a bunch of
those, right? It's been a ton of,
and then you see the Energy Simpson,
for example. Did he blame somebody?
Blame know somebody probably blamed
him, you think? Nah, I'm kidding.